hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing why Fred and George
Weasley never noticed Peter Pettigrew in
case Gabba's the rat on the magically
revealing Marauder's Map I suppose to
start with we can address the question
of why would they well as we learned
near the end of Harry Potter's third
year at Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry the Marauders map has the
capability to reveal each and every
person roaming the hallowed Halls of the
school regardless of their form it
represents witches and wizards with a
DOT that has a corresponding name which
is always their true identity again
regardless of any magic that may make
them appear differently when confronted
in person and it is through the map that
Harry discovers a number of unsettling
secrets that have to do with the night
his parents were murdered including the
fact that Peter Pettigrew his father's
mate who supposedly died that same night
is alive
how does he discover this he sees him on
the Marauders map but I'm getting ahead
of myself to rewind a bit throughout
Harry's third year at school he
initially believes Sirius Black and
escaped convict from The Wizarding
prison of Azkaban to be his father's
disgrace friend who betrayed Harry's
parents and revealed their secret
location to Lord Voldemort an act which
led to both of their deaths but as more
and more secrets come to light Harry
learns that it was actually James and
sirius's other friend Peter Pettigrew
who betrayed them both sharing James
Lillian Harry's Hiding Place with
Voldemort and then framing Sirius for
both this betrayal and the murders of a
dozen innocent people including himself
in fact Peter even cut off his own
finger believing this would be enough to
convince The Wizarding community that he
was dead which it indeed did and escaped
transformed as his unregistered animagus
form as a rat from there Peter fled the
scene of the crime scampering away as
his Road himself and went in search of a
Wizarding family to take him in xerius
later accuses Peter of doing so in order
to keep his ear to the ground for news
of Lord Voldemort's return which seems
to be exactly what he did as we know the
Wizarding family that Peter ended up
with was none other than the Weasleys
now how exactly Peter entered the home
of Ron and his family as their pet rat
has never been confirmed but it seems
entirely reasonable to think that Peter
made his way to the borough the home of
the Weasleys knowing of their reputation
as good but rather poor people who had
connections to the ministry of magic
through Arthur's job and the Order of
the Phoenix through Molly's family
it stands the reason that Peter may have
assumed that these compassionate
well-connected people would be willing
to adopt a rat and so he waited out in
their Garden for one of the family's
many children to find him Peter's
presence in the Weasley's yard wouldn't
have been odd at all considering he was
in his rat form and his breed is often
described throughout the series as being
a common Garden rat so I imagine that a
young Percy Weasley who would have been
around five years old at the time came
across Peter and asked his parents if he
could keep him as the Weasleys didn't
have much in the way of disposable
income they said yes and told Percy that
this rat would be his pet when the time
came for him to attend Hogwarts thereby
alleviating the need for them to
purchase him an animal familiar later on
from there Peter was taken in as a pet
of the Weasley family and went on to
live with them for more than 10 years
and scabbers the rat until he was
discovered on the Marauders map in
Harry's third year at school not by Fred
and George I might add but by Harry and
later Remus Lupine it's also worth
mentioning that Harry only noticed Peter
on the map during that school year since
it was then that he acquired the
Marauders map a gift given to him by the
Weasley twins red and George this brings
us to the fact that the twins weren't
the first owners of the magical
Marauders map which showed a detailed
blueprint of Hogwarts Castle and the
surrounding grounds
it was originally created by Harry's own
father James as well as his three
closest mates Sirius Black whom is
Lupine and Peter Pettigrew how Fred and
George got their hands on the map seems
to have been the result of these two
setting off a dunbarm in the school
which landed them in the caretaker
filters office while being detained the
twins noticed a draw marked confiscated
and highly dangerous they broke into it
of course Van the Marauder's Map stole
it and managed to figure out how to
operate it in terms of how they achieved
this last part there's been a bit of
contentious debates around this topic by
fans however considering the response JK
Rowling provided in an interview some
years ago it seems rather likely that
twins achieved access to the map by
trying different phrases in an effort to
get the map to reveal itself
Rowling suggested that perhaps the map
itself helped them out flickering to
life here and there with phrases that
were closed to the actual passcode in
any case Fred and George did manage to
get the Marauders map to reveal itself
to them perhaps it could just tell that
they wanted to get up to Mischief which
of course was what the map had been
originally created to do this means they
then would have been able to see
everyone listed on the map who was
present at Hogwarts and as we covered
earlier the Marauders map names all
people roaming the grounds of the school
by their true identities so how is it
that Fred and George never noticed Peter
bettergrew on the map he would have been
there right from the time they learned
how to work the map as he was originally
Percy's pet and Percy was a couple years
ahead of the Twins and as we've
discussed the map couldn't be fooled by
anime guy apologies potions or even
invisibility cloaks so Peter's real name
not scabbers would have shown up every
year that he was brought to Hogwarts
wouldn't they have thought it range for
this Peter person to always be
essentially on top of Percy then Ron
sleeping in their beds and attending all
the exact same classes as their two
brothers how is it possible that the
twins never noticed him
well despite this appearing to be a
glaring plot hole I think there's
actually a rather reasonable explanation
for starters Peter pettico's name
wouldn't have meant much to Fred and
George because well why would it
relative to the Weasley family Peter
would have just been a wizard who
perished at the hands of Voldemort and
his Death Eaters and think about it even
if Molly and Arthur had known exactly
what supposedly had taken place between
Sirius and Peter that fateful night in
which the Potters were killed why would
they share that horrific tale with their
children and so again the name Peter
Pettigrew wouldn't have meant anything
to any of the Weasley children including
Fred and George and even if it had there
very well could have been some random
student at Hogwarts with the same name
as a wizard who had supposedly died more
than a decade ago no need for the twins
to question its presence on the map or
even think twice about it in terms of
Peter's constant proximity to Percy and
then Ron there are two possible
explanations for this in my opinion one
people were displayed as little moving
dots on the Marauders map in the
Gryffindor dorms in common room there
would have been so many dots clustered
together representing all of the
students who room there that it would
have been quite difficult to discern
exactly how close Percy Ron and Peter
were then there's the fact that Fred and
George said that they primarily use the
map when they first uncovered it but by
the time they handed it over to Harry in
his and Ron's third year they had it so
memorized they barely looked at it
anymore this would account for why they
wouldn't have noticed that Peter
Pettigrew was initially always with
Percy Before Peter was handed down to
Ron only to then always be with Ron once
he started at school it's also
incredibly reasonable to assume that the
twins weren't overly focused on the
areas of the castle that Peter would
have been residing in that is Gryffindor
Tower and the classrooms that Percy and
Ron attended with scabbers in tow it
seems altogether more likely that they
would have been much more focused on
seeking out the hidden tunnels and
passageways as well is keeping a lookout
for filch and professors as they snuck
around getting up to Mischief around the
school
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think why do
you think fret and George never noticed
Peter Pettigrew on the emeraldas map
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out the content on Spotify
as well as extra content on my second
Channel Harry Potter Theory extra until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live